CARTER MORGAN: Today we're
talking about Cloud Spanner
ecosystem restoration and
Chrome browser Cloud Management.
I'm Carter Morgan, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud Spanner is a fully
managed relational database
with unlimited scale,
strong consistency,
and up to five nines
of availability.
To achieve the best
performance characteristics,
it's advisable to launch your
production application when
Spanner is in a warm state
with splits already balanced
across all of the
server resources.
Check out the blog for
a step-by-step resource.
Protecting the Earth's ecosystem
from further degradation
and improving outcomes for
the wildlife and communities
that rely on them needs to be
a focus for the next decade
of climate action.
But where do we start?
Head to the blog to learn more
about how Restore is helping
to solve for knowledge gaps
and accelerate restoration
with data.
IT and security teams have
a lot on their plate--
from supporting the transition
to new work environments
to preventing an increasing
number of security attacks--
and as more and more work
is done in the browser,
it's important for IT and
security professionals
to look at the browser
as a critical piece
of infrastructure to keep
their organization secure.
Chrome Browser Cloud
Management gives IT teams
a simple and efficient
way to manage and secure
their browser across
multiple operating systems,
all from the Cloud.
Check out the link for examples.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
And if you have any
thoughts or ideas,
leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.